bienvenue dans cette nouvelle série de
vidéos consacrées un outil très utile
pour les enseignants qui veut leur
organiser des cours en dehors des murs
de la classe est ici nous sommes en
période de confinement avec le coït 19
et donc ça pourrait être un outil très
utile en ce moment on attend de voir
google me tète un outil qui va permettre
d'organiser des visioconférences jusqu'à
100 utilisateurs avec la licence
classique mais jusqu'à 250 utilisateurs
pendant cette période de confinement il
y a quatre vidéos consacrées à cet outil
aujourd'hui la vidéo va vous proposer la
mise en place de google mythe dans vos
classes comment faire pour créer ces
sessions avec vos élèves
[Musique]
la première façon de créer un google
need et de partir de google classroom ce
qui serait très facile pour les élèves
étant donné que normalement ils ont
accès généralement à cette plateforme
pour créer la réunion vous rejoignez un
court et dans ce cours vous aller dans
les paramètres c'est-à-dire la molette
un peu plus bas vous retrouvez le logo
google mythe et vous cliquez simplement
sur générer un lien bits
voilà votre réunion est créée sera une
réunion permanente dans ce cas ci qui
sera dédié à la classe alors vous pouvez
éventuellement caché l'adresse de la
réunion aux élèves
on veut la garder actif et ici vous avez
bien l'adresse avec cette simple adresse
en la mettant dans un navigateur ont
rejoint directement la réunion donc en
fait avec ce lien c'est un des axes et
les plus faciles pour arriver à la
réunion ici je peux copier directement
et je peux par exemple envoyer un mail
ou créer un poste dans cars room avec ce
lien à l'attention des élèves
n'oubliez pas d'enregistrer désormais
apparaît dans l'intitulé du court le
lien vers la réunion ou la
visioconférence dans l'onglet travaux et
devoirs vous aurez également une icône
google mythe qui apparaîtra ici et qui
vous permettra de directement rejoindre
la réunion mais c'est aussi valable
évidemment pour les élèves
[Musique]
la deuxième manière d'opérer peut-être
moins intéressante pour les élèves et
peut-être plus dans le cadre de
collaboration avec les collègues et de
partir de l'agenda je peux choisir une
date est à cette date planifier une
réunion
je mettrai évidemment une heure précise
et je vais aller dans autre option dans
autre option apparaît ajouter une
visioconférence en gouttes vide voilà il
ne faut pas faire plus pour créer une
visioconférence maintenant vous pouvez
éventuellement invitez vos collègues à
participer à cette réunion vous envoyer
une notification via leur boîte mail qui
leur demandera s'il veulent bien
participer à cette réunion
maintenant vous voyez qu ici apparaît
bien l'événement que je viens de créer
avec le lien vers le hang out mythe ou
le google mythe troisième manière de
créer un google mythes et de partir
directement de l'application dans la
barre de recherche tapez google mythe et
cliquez sur le premier lien vous
arriverez sur cet écran vous voyez que
les réunions qui ont été déjà prévus ou
planifié apparaissent ici il faut bien
sûr avoir créé la réunion google mythe
via l'agenda et non pas via google fasse
comme si non vous n'aurez pas la
planification qui apparaîtra dans google
mythe vous cliquez sur l'onglet
rejoindre démarrer une réunion est ici
vous vous donnez un nom à la réunion
vous voulez mettre en place vous venez
de créer d'une troisième manière un
google mythe
il vous suffira dans ce cas-ci de
communiquer le mot clé que vous venez de
taper pour que vos collègues puissent
eux-mêmes rejointe le google mythe
bien sûr si vous participez à la réunion
vous pourrez toujours avoir les
informations récapitulative ici copier
ces informations et les communiquer à
vos collègues vous retrouvez toujours un
lien lié dédié à la réunion que vous
venez de créer
je vous remercie pour votre attention et
votre soutien à ces vidéos
je vous souhaite un bon travail une
bonne prise en main de l'outil et je
vous dis à très bientôt
[Musique]
où